so
what is biomutant in a nutshell
biomutant is an
open world post-apocalyptic kung fu
fable
basically in terms of structure it's
like sell the breath of the wild i guess
but the feedback that's you know that
we've been getting over the years it's a
kind of a strange weird good mix
between ratchet and clank devil may cry
batman arkham yeah and a couple of other
influences
so it's truly an open world game eight
by eight
kilometers filled with a lot of weird
events and fun things to find
i think the primary thing that we worked
a lot with is the control that the
player have
over the character customization we have
the possibility for the player you know
to to set the attributes and
by newton that's uh tightly connected or
integrated with the way that the
character uh looks but the player is
like
completely free to morph their own
uh breed we call it a breed but mammal
if you will
and eventually you know people have a
lot of assumptions on
what kind of animal this is but for me
and i guess the team
we have allowed the player to make what
i call
you know more like a muppet
[Music]
and with carrot customization you know
it goes all the way down to
crafting bits onto your clothes or hats
or
pants or whatnot i guess the most
important thing is the arsenal of the
weapons i mean it's an
action role-playing game right so we're
focusing on
the action parts of you know the
role-playing aspect
each like part that you can find for
weapons and gear also comes with
like a material a quality aspect so
they can be more damaged or of a higher
quality material
just mentioning that you don't have to
repair
but you can actually upgrade things that
are broken but they will never
diminish in terms of of their material
qualities like in zelda for example we
don't do that
in the game you have six different
tribes uh so they're all composed of
you know leader asifu if you will that
have mastered
a specific wangful combat style
and trained as disciples in in that so
these
tribes are now in conflict basically
there are
three tribes that have what we call a
light
aura so basically a good karma if you
will if you want to paint
black and white and there are three
tribes that have like a dark
aura eventually at the start of the game
you will find that you have to choose
an ally so one of these six tribes
as you move along or go further into the
game you're free at any time
to change your allegiance but at the
start of the game you you choose one of
these two
tribes and basically at that point the
state of the world
is represented by a huge tree that's
at the heart of the eight by eight
kilometer over world
so it's a representation of
the world either going under
or the world surviving so this is all
tied to the
tree of life
a light or a tribe they want to save the
world
so make sure that the tree survives and
also then generating the other tribes
whilst allying with dark or a tribe
would mean the opposite they believe
that the only way
that you can move forward is to
make sure there's kind of a cleansing i
guess
so making sure that everything that's
bad in the world
kind of goes under so you have a rebirth
and start on you
if that makes sense so you're very free
to make this choice but also bear in
mind that
that will affect the ending of the game
obviously game being called by mutant
has to have some form of
mutations slash abilities right
there's quite a wide range of them
primarily we have the bimutations so
those are kind of
more physical abilities if you will for
example you can spawn a mushroom in
front of you
that has multiple uses if i used to use
that one as an example in terms of
creative freedom for you as a player
combining this
jumping up on the mushroom with let's
say just
electricity shooting out from your
fingers like the emperor in star wars
or once the character is airborne like
your enemy
uh just going up there unleashing some
other
kind of strange abilities i don't want
to go into all of them but
the other aspect is the psi mutations so
those are more like your
you know x-men style abilities if you
will like for example levitate
which again can give you both
exploration opportunities but also then
you can use it in combat in conjunction
with other abilities and
obviously ranged combat so that will
give you an advantage i guess
you were wanting to keep on exploring
the world
because you're wondering what's going to
be you know around the next corner
and i guess the hope that we have as a
group as a team
is that that's gonna be the unifying
factor in terms of
people playing the game and giving us
feedback uh
that we that it's notable that the game
has a soul
or a why that is a little bit unique and
special
that's my highest hope for the game i
[Music]
guess
you